starting tomorrow anyone who needs help  during a mental health emergency can  call or text the number 988  experts believe the new national number  will help get more people get the help  and the access to support that they need  it's separate from 9-1-1 which often  does lead to interactions with police  especially for communities of color  relying on law enforcement can be so  fraught that's why it's really important  for us as a nation to embrace 988  suicide rates in the u.s increased by 30  percent from the year 2000 to 2020  according to cdc and the risk is  especially high for children with  experts warning the pandemic hit them  the hardest